wissen sie schon wen sie wählen dann
gestern der sollte bei dieser
entscheidung ja eigentlich helfen hütte
beginnt diese sendung natürlich mit der
analyse des tv kampfes gestern abend ein
boxkampf ist ja vor allem deshalb so
spannend weil auch der vermeintlich
schwächere gewinnen kann durch einen
gezielten treffer oder run glücks schlag
einen lucky punch und natürlich wartet
man als zuschauer genau darauf im
vorfeld des schlagabtausches gestern
abend waren sich alle einig dass armin
laschet genau so einen ko sieg brauchen
würde um die kampfrichter die wähler
also sie noch für sich gewinnen zu
können selbst ein punktsieg nach zwölf
runden tencel würde nicht reichen das
wusste laschet natürlich und deshalb war
ja gleich angriffslustig aber scholz
steckte die schläge ein verließ sich auf
seine deckung während annalena baerbock
wie die richterin wirkte die den boxern
aus dem weg geht am ende gab es keinen
ko schlag und die kampfrichter erklärten
scholz deshalb in allen blitzumfragen
zum sieger damit stellt sich am morgen
danach die frage was das jetzt für armin
laschet im kampf um das kanzleramt hier
im studio bild chef julian reichelt
morgen für morgen wird ritter wider
hatte dein fazit zum gestrigen abend was
das jetzt für angelastet mein fazit
lautet auf jeden fall dass es eben
diesen ko-schlag nicht gab
prominentester zeuge dafür übrigens mal
wieder markus söder vor dem trio war ja
vollkommen klar ist hieße armin laschet
muss hart zuschlagen amos im prinzip
durch ko gewinnen um sich aus diesen
umfragen zurück kämpfen zu können
gestern abend dann der scheinbar
freundliche tweet von markus söder
klarer
punktsieg für armin laschet das ist aber
genau das was armin laschet nicht
brauchte wir werden unseren zuschauern
ihr gleich erste umfragen zeigen die
umfragen des kerls von gestern für mich
der interessanteste punkt und das kann
man fast um im bild zu bleiben als das
handtuch werfen werden die erste frage
der kollegin bei ard und zdf
schließen würden sie auch in eine rot
schwarze koalition eintreten als
vizekanzler und armin laschet wollte
diese frage nicht beantworten hat sogar
ganz bewusst gesagt ich beantwortet
diese frage nicht ich beantworte keine
würde fragen übersetzung armin laschet
schließt nicht aus in eine raw schwarze
koalition einzutreten geführt von olaf
scholz das wird die große politische
debatte dieser woche gibt es wieder eine
groko aber diesmal unter spd führung der
ist zahlen angesprochen wir wollen wir
uns einmal anschauen julian wer war
besser wer war schlechter in free l
gestern abend die einschätzung der
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer schauen wir
jetzt ganz genau uns mal an denn da muss
man sagen der konzern lasse dann doch
ein bisschen aufholen dennoch es gibt
ein ganz klares urteil der wählerinnen
und wähler die gestern zugeschaut haben
und stahl liegt weiterhin olaf scholz
vorne wer besser wäre schlechter laschet
war zumindest zu sagen 35 prozent besser
als erwartet hier sehen wir einmal wie
er hat sich wie beim tv duell geschlagen
es ist die grafik leider wieder
verschwunden aber 35 prozent sagen
laschet war besser als erwartet 12 sagen
schlechter als erwartet 53 prozent sagen
er war wie erwartet also irgendwie hat
sich da nicht so wahnsinnig viel getan
scholz dagegen 27 prozent besser 15
prozent schlechter und auch 58 prozent
sagen ja das war wie erwartet ein abend
mit wenig überraschungen offenbar müsste
annalena baerbock 53 prozent sagen sie
war besser als erwartet nur acht prozent
sagen sie war schlechter als erwartet
und 38 prozent sagen sie war wie
erwartet also 58 prozent da konnte sie
dann noch einmal richtig punkten stand
ja in der mitte zwischen den beiden
manchmal beim split screen und das sag
ich sehr sehr witzig aus sie hat in der
mitte gerade in die kamera geschaut und
die anderen beiden haben sie haben sie
angeschaut und sie hat ja auch immer
geartete das war ja eigentlich ganz
geschickt wie sie das gemacht hatte
wartete dass die beiden sich gegenseitig
den schlagabtausch liefern um dann am
ende zu sagen so das war ihre
vergangenheitsbewältigung jetzt schauen
wir nach vorn es war geschickt es hat
aber auch irgendwie gezeigt an der ligna
bernburg ist nicht mehr im rennen um die
kanzlerschaft ist nicht mehr im rennen
um das kanzleramt annalena baerbock war
gestern ein bisschen die zeit time
keeper wie man so schön sagt jetzt sagt
moment moment olaf scholz gerichte nicht
genug redezeit die uhr bei ihm läuft
weiter sie hat einmal darauf hingewiesen
dass im studio irgendwas umgefallen ist
das waren schon die bemerkenswertesten
momente es gibt allerdings das muss man
sagen zwei zahlen die ami laschet
vielleicht doch noch ein bisschen
hoffnung machen ich habe hier gerade
noch einmal nachgeschaut und das ist bei
der forschungsgruppe wahlen
die frage wen hätten sie am liebsten als
bundeskanzler der sagen bei olaf scholz
46 prozent klar vorne aber neun
prozentpunkte schwächer als vor dem
trierer armin laschet 8 20 prozent klar
hinten klar zweite aber neun
prozentpunkte mehr als vor dem tri l und
jetzt gucken wir die gleiche umfrage hat
uns noch mal an er bei infratest dimap
dass scholz stabil bei 43 prozent und
armin laschet auch da weit abgeschlagen
auf dem zweiten platz 24 prozent
arbeiten +5 das heißt armin laschet ist
von 19 auf 24 gestern gegangen das ist
immerhin ein plus von satten 25 prozent
das ist die zahl auf die man heute im
konrad-adenauer-haus guckt thomas noch
ein wichtiger punkt zu dem was du
angesprochen dass armin laschet und das
konrad adenauer haus haben immer gesagt
bei diesem trio werden 20 millionen
menschen umgucken zu gucken 20 millionen
menschen da bieten wir das ding um war
nur die hälfte das da geht es nicht um
einschaltquoten sondern da geht es
tatsächlich um die logik des teams
laschet womit haben sie gerechnet die
hatten doppelt so viele zuschauer
erwartet wie am ende da dh man hat halt
logischerweise auch nur die hälfte der
menschen die man eigentlich ein
gerechnet hatte die man wieder
vielleicht auf seine seite sind
interessanter vergleich weil man noch
einmal auf 2005 schaut als schröder
dagegen merkel antritt als es auch darum
gehen kann es einen neuanfang geben da
noch 21 millionen menschen zugeschaut
jetzt also 11 man sagt ja in den usa den
schönen satz politics ist showbusiness
vorgibt politik ist showbusiness für
hässliche da muss man ganz klar sagen
das ist natürlich in heutigen zeit muss
man es vielleicht einmal kurz einordnen
ja das ist natürlich
humorvoll gemeint aber man muss ganz
klar sagen wir haben es gestern gesehen
gerhard schröder wir erinnern uns war
ein showman gerhard schröder war
showbusiness das was wir gestern gesehen
haben hatte mit großer emotionaler
politik show ja ich gar nichts zu tun
lasst uns mal gemeinsam bisschen hinter
die kulissen blicken denn direkt nach
dem duell nach beim rausgehen da hat
terrorexperte im team laschet neumann
die umfragezahlen an lamy lasche
durchgegeben und da schon mal rein
zudem spielen
sehen ja das war genau der moment in dem
zumindest peter neumann peter neumann
der terrorexperte
sicher bisschen gefreut und armin
laschet gute laune machen wollte hat ihm
da die banken gezeigt wie die ja
immerhin gewachsen sind ich würde sagen
man hat in armin laschet gesicht auch
wenn es zu teilen hinter der maske
verborgen war jetzt nicht gerade
wirkliche euphorie gemerkt der kann da
er sowieso raus geschlendert und
ging nicht er ging nicht wie ein sieger
nach einem ko schlag das muss man sagen
trotzdem wurde er so gefeiert da kann
man mal kurz reinschauen
im konrad adenauer haus direkt im
anschluss an diese szene
da wurde gesungen mit der uschi und dem
lässt wie aber lässt sie sind gar nicht
mit dass müssen uns wirklich genauer
anschauen ist ein jubel szenen
[Musik]
ja das sind also
gesänge die man eigentlich aus
fußballstadien klingt und wir kennen
wenn man wenn man ein bisschen in diesem
in diesem spiel bleiben will in diesem
bild dann ist es eigentlich so ein
bisschen als hätte bielefeld nur zu viel
gegen bayern verloren aber die fans
feiern trotzdem aus trotz ja das ist die
junge union die junge union hat sich in
den letzten wochen trotz der schlechten
umfragewerte offenbar komplett in rage
gedacht und gesungen ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher ob solche bilder noch zum
wahlkampf im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert passen es wirkt halt einfach
absurd ja es ist die zeit des kämpfens
es für armin laschet ist es nicht die
zeit des beschönigen es ist nicht die
zeit der sprechchöre es gibt den
standard es gibt keine alternative zum
gewinnen hat das duell gestern nun mal
verloren das ist die wahl bittere weit
er ist zwar gewachsen aber eher zu
wachsen ist kein sieg hat das duell
gestern verloren ich glaube eine truppe
die eine niederlage so feiert er läuft
große gefahr
schon die nächste niederlage für sich zu
bauen weil sie offenbar überhaupt keine
sensibilität dafür hat dass das ding
gestern verloren worden ist obwohl armin
laschet einen sieg brauchte man sollte
niederlagen nicht feiern wie sie gesund
ist die nächste niederlage garantiert
schießt du wenn wir ihnen da ich finde
das video auch wirklich so ein bisschen
als würde man sieht leslie mandoki das
geschieht
im hintergrund klatscht auch den
eindruck das ist armin laschet ein
bisschen unangenehm wie er da
ich weiß nicht ob es ihm unangenehm ist
sollte besser koordiniert seien die
menschen die um einen kanzlerkandidaten
drumherum stimmen sind immer eine
botschaft wir haben es eben schon mal
gesagt politics ist showbusiness die
menschen die neben politikern stehen
sind eine botschaft warum steht da kein
friedrich merz der immer noch für viele
wähler ein magnet ist für die cdu kein
mensch auf der welt
wählt die union wegen so sehr ich sie
mag so sehr ich sie schätze großartiges
soziales engagement kein mensch auf der
welt wird die union wegen glas und noch
weniger menschen wählen die union wegen
leslie mandoki das ist dass das das ist
einfach nicht die botschaft die ich an
so einem abend ausstrahlen muss ich muss
umgeben sein rami laschet hat auch in
zukunft 7 armin laschet hat doch
menschen auf die ersetzt die müssen
neben mir stehen wenn ich das bild sehen
muss sich doch als wähler sagen da ist
sich nur armin laschet da sind auch noch
die und die und der und deswegen will
ich armin laschet und dann kommt darin
steht letztlich mandoki der übrigens
einer der engsten freunde von viktor
orban ist ja also für den großen
europäer für den großen europäer armin
laschet ist viktor orban jetzt
eigentlich keine gestalt mit den in
deren
freundschaftliche nähe also ich
eigentlich begeben sollte auf so einem
entscheidenden wahlkampf bild ich habe
noch eine skurrile szene gestern abend
und zwar ein video auf twitter gepostet
pressesprecher der cdu in sachsen jan
schäfer das hat er kurz kurze zeit
später weil sie manchmal peinlich war
wieder herausgenommen aber wir haben es
natürlich schon mal kurz rein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja ja fucking hell kann man da nur sagen
wenn man das sieht wer um gottes willen
ist darauf gekommen also erstens wir
erzwingen es zur not was heißt denn bei
einer wahl wir erzwingen ist zur not das
können wir ja immer noch freiwillig
entscheiden wen wir wählen die cdu
sollte doch nicht im adenauer-haus jetzt
sagen wenn wir nicht gewinnen dann
erzwingen wir das zur not und dann muss
man natürlich sagen ist wenn man wenn
das jemand gemacht hätte der den film
vielleicht mal gesehen hat etwas
problematische etwas problematische
szene ja 200 männer
alle wie die gorillaz da ist nicht viel
mit diversity alle voll auf drogen alle
bis in die haarspitzen zugeguckt
trommeln sich dann auf die auf die brust
und das ist dann das motivation video
man sieht wie peinlich ist der union ist
und wie stellt man dann die alarmglocken
angehen weil es sofort auf twitter
wieder gelöscht wurde aber man fragt
sich ja gott wer kommt darauf dieses
video dann wenigstens diesen schlechten
untertiteln da da nochmal zum
aufputschen einzuspielen das sagt halt
echt schon sehr sehr sehr viel über
über über das chaos was da auch
teilweise im team herrscht und die frage
wie wollen wir eigentlich kommunizieren
ja als als gorillas wie bei wolf of wall
street oder vielleicht mal mit einer
klaren botschaft die die menschen
interessiert wollen wir wirklich singen
nach einem verlorenen duell armin
laschet wird kanzler oder wollen wir
dafür arbeiten das armenische kanzler
wird ich glaube da sitzen die
prioritäten noch nicht so richtig
klappen sie glauben selbst noch dran
also das scheint auch so die videos ews
heute morgen sehen nach dem trial am tag
nach dem trend dass manchmal fast so ein
zug von verzweiflungstat zu haben.von
wir müssen uns jetzt auch noch selber
überzeugen dass wir das schaffen na ja
das muss man natürlich auch sagen in dem
wahlkampf muss man sich auch sehr
überzeugt sind brutale wochen für alle
ja das sind teilweise 18 20 stunden tage
für das ganze wahlkampfteam da muss man
wie man wie so schön beim wir kennen
alle beim schlossgespenst hui buh sich
teilweise auch einen eigenen haaren aus
dem schlamm herausziehen das gehört
schon ein bisschen dazu aber wenn man
lauter videos kostet die man hinterher
gleich wieder löscht weil es ihm
unangenehm ist dann waren vielleicht
nicht die richtigen videos
bis da also sozusagen als leonardo
dicaprio ins sehr leonardo dicaprio vom
vom rhein
nach dem trial wie bei uns im bild live
die richtigen fragen gestellt da war
unter anderem roger köppel herausgeber
der weltwoche zu gast und der hat nicht
leonardo dicaprio sondern jemand anderen
im kopf gehabt haben wir auch noch mal
kurz
mit loud steht ist er für mich so etwas
wie die etwas
leichtere variante von tom hanks desto
der tom hanks der deutschen politik
allerdings etwas
vielleicht ja nicht ganz so klar ist
vorbei ist tom hanks ist mein lieblings
kosten ich sagen der beste schauspieler
war wirklich schauspielen kann und
verschiedene rollen einnehmen kann aber
wir wollen ja keine schauspieler als
politiker ja ich glaube was rutsche
koppe uns damit sagte das finde ich
eigentlich ganz treffend tom hanks
spielt ja immer so ein bisschen den
zurückhaltenden stillen helden tom
hengst ist ja ist ja eigentlich nicht
berühmt geworden für seine
revolverheld action rollen sondern für
menschen die sozusagen in der stille zum
helden werden so still ja trifft es auch
was den wahlkampf von amina schon an
geht an manchen tagen ganz gut die trips
selige variante eines stillen helden
will nun wirklich keiner sein ich glaube
was er uns was hat er quasi armin
laschet zugerufen hat war eine
aufforderung laut nach vorne klare sätze
das ist ja doch die entscheidende frage
welchen satz erinnern wir alle von
gestern also ich erinnere dass er rot
schwarz nicht ausschließt und sonst
schwierig ja und das nicht genug
[Musik]